[Music]
in today's video we want to show y'all
what we do in patreon
so whatever you said let's jump right
into it
patreon what is it so patreon is
to allow to answer a lot of people's
questions that we've been getting on a
common basis
it's just a platform where we post
videos that are not part of the main
youtube channel that you see in public
right so it's subscription based we post
little goofy
silly videos that could be anywhere from
10 minutes to up to over an hour
like the one you're going to see today
we post whatever we want it's not really
for formal it's not really scripted like
our main theme topics
but we can't post everything on youtube
obviously for many reasons right so
this is the real us this is the raw us
and
this episode you're gonna see right now
very good example of a typical patreon
exclusive video that we see
we got tiers ranging from the lowest one
which is like five dollars a month
and you get things like exclusive videos
just like this on a regular basis we got
higher tiers where you can hop on a live
stream with us
when we go live on our main channel we
got other ones where you can uh you can
do weekly
or monthly consultations with us get
some advice from us
get our personal you know inboxes stuff
like that so
with that being said rami should they
wait on this or should they just hop on
they should hop on as soon as possible
go check it out
you heard it here first man even more i
edit that video
into something uh perfect for the funny
moments
with that i know tell us something in
spanish before i let them go
nah there you go nah
that is spanish for no listening
[Music]
welcome back to your patreon exclusives
we are hosted with
uh angel whose auda is showing we are
hosted with
rami and we are hosted with your boy
fired
so we're gonna quickly question it's not
the order bro
how's the no doubter i heard it's it's
the knees can show
i heard it's like a mid thigh down
mid thigh up we can see like the belly
button
we can see like the inside of your like
you can see that bro
it's about i'm telling y'all it's it's
just the angle right now but like
literally i'm looking at it like my mid
thigh is covered by my pants
like my mid thigh is right here but like
the angle
it looks like you can see everything
really like this is
a very big portion of my leg if i go
like this
so now you're just seeing the knee bro
at the end of the day you do you but
this will be a damn funny
clip for the highlights now as i was
saying we got a question
from a patron by the name of mikko angel
and we got miko on her asking us how do
i how do i manage my time
you know i feel like i'm running out of
time every day i don't know how to
manage my time
i try to do all these different things
but then i don't get what actually needs
to be done
and what do y'all have to say so i'm
gonna go first
be cool the most important i know bro
like
his name's not they say i was gonna say
the most important thing
for you is the rule of threes this is
just me personally
every single night before i go to bed
all right and i say this to make it easy
on you
but what i actually do is i write down
three things for like
two three weeks at a time but what i
would recommend you guys
before you go to bed write down three
things that you need to get done the
next day
no matter what happens you get these
three things done all right very easy
three most important things second thing
is
the pareto principle so a lot of people
don't know
what the pareto principle is do you two
know
no okay this is also known as the 80 20
rule or the rule of 80 20.
now what this means is
out of all of the different things that
you got to do to get one
desired goal 80 of
the things that you got to do only
result for 20
of the results but 20
of the things you got to do will result
for 80 of the gains
quick example of this we're talking
about working out
or let's say mma that unhooked us of all
the things you got to do let's list 10
things
you could say sleep you could say
nutrition you could say training you
would say
uh hydration you could say the brand of
protein powder you got to take
gotta say whey protein isolate or whey
protein concentrate
vegan or not vegan you know there's so
many different things that will help you
to the goal
my invitation to you guys and girls is
20 of those things
of all those things will lead to 80
of the results of you getting to the ufc
you being a professional enemy athlete
20 and they will result to 80
why because these are the big key bread
and butter things
like sleep would be one of the 20 things
training
um diet things like this you know
the time you eat not going to be part of
that 20 that leads to 80
right uh the actual brand if you take
optimum nutrition protein or body
fortress not going to matter bro
whether you sleep in you know at this
time or that time
not going to make big changes right but
the little things that are 20
they're going to lead to 80 right now
the 80
of the things right the brand of the
protein powder
what color shirt you wear when you train
right if you train
at this time versus that time if you uh
you know use these weights versus those
weights
right these 80 these big little
you know not important things they're
only going to lead to 20
of the results but they take up 80 of
the energy time
you get what i mean another example is
let's say study
right you you can you know there's doing
the work
then there's brain enhancing supplements
then there's
good rest which is where memory
consolidates right because you need that
for
performing well there's uh practice
questions
right instead of just doing the exam or
midterm there's uh
writing notes versus typing notes right
there's so many different things
but of all the things of the 100 of the
things to do 20
will result in 80 of you getting that a
plus
and that 20 i would say is like sleep
going over things practice questions
that's it bro
the 80 the big clutter should i type
should i
write what color highlighter should i
use uh should i sit should i be in bed
bro they will only result to the 20 of
your grade it doesn't really matter
you want to take it to level 3 advanced
is
we got 100 energy right and we can only
put it in one thing
here's my invitation if you put in
twenty percent into bodybuilding right
i wanna i don't know to answer this you
only put in the 20
that's the most important that will give
you the percent rate
your output is twenty percent or your
output is eight percent
yes or no what was your input
twenty percent twenty percent how much
more
time and energy do you have out of your
whole reservoir
eighty percent let's say you then put in
another twenty percent
into another avenue but only into the
most important twenty percent
how much output do you get in that now
you have 160 percent
you have 160 because 80 percent from the
first one 80 percent reset one
let's say you do this and you
strategically do five different avenues
right and you put in 20 of the big main
important ones
you do that 20 into each bro you have
400 percent
compared to just putting in 100 into one
thing where you get 100 out
if you don't burn yourself out or
distract yourself and you know
get you go on your phone for two hours
if you only focus on the main bread and
butter
look at that bro that that that's also
similar to doing
let's say putting 40 into two things
and getting 160 like angel said you
still get 160
or 80 which basically is like pretty
decent at two things
and you have 60 of your time left
to do whatever you want to pray to
read quran to train to play video games
whatever you want to do
or you could push um 60
into three different avenues and get out
240 percent
which means you're 80 in three different
areas which is pretty damn amazing since
most people aren't even 80
in one area so my invitation to you is
focus on these big 20 and just put
energy into that
yes after that point you've already got
80
results the remaining 20 is going to
take time through all those 80
things and for the 80 useless things i
recommend
only do them if you really need to get
100 on something right
perfect example is the great thing bro
before i let you guys go
um you want to get an 80 it's not gonna
be hard bro
right you just need to put in that 20
just do the work
you know recall go to sleep eat
that's it but then to get from 80 to 85
takes so much more work bro
i know you guys know this you get from
85 to 90 bro you probably got to study
hours
the people that are getting 100
consistently are probably spending 100
of their time at school
so i would rather spend 20 percent of
my time getting 80 which is like an a a
minus
and then put 20 something else bro yeah
and then put 20
something else but the big five for me
that i put 20 into each four for me
not equal in measure but five priorities
of mine
would be first one allah right so
prayer learning about islam reading
hadith
just things like that this podcast that
would be one right because they're all
you know intertwined two would be diet
three would be training
four would be sleep and five would be
connections
social life keeping you know everything
straight with people
you know roommate if you're married just
these things
but that's just me that's time
management for me yeah subscribe i feel
like
god was speaking through you because
yesterday man like
i was uh making dua after my prayer
and i was just like allah
like just please give me
the ability to just be receptive and
like see
what needs to be done next like give me
the
the the ability to be receptive and then
the ability to adapt and just like start
doing
these things you know because it the big
changes are obviously the big changes
and
like bro i'm i'm just shocked
that like you were saying everything it
was just like then you just mentioned
the mma thing that
it all was just lining up perfectly bro
like it's like all these gears in my
head were like
just clicking perfectly bro so jessica
just cut that hair bro well yeah bro i i
appreciate
it and here's the thing quick side note
is if you're in a position to help
anyone don't don't turn it down because
you could be
the answer to that person's prayer to
that person's dua
you could be what allah is sending and
you want to say no you want to block
that blessing come on
there's enough money for everyone to eat
there's enough blessings for everyone to
thrive
there's enough women for everyone to
have four wives if they want to
so why limit yourself and have the scar
city mentality but yeah i'm gonna let
romney go
allah i mean i don't really have much to
say i'm in the same boat as angels found
a lot because i'm
like starting with uh i have school
coming up i have some other things you
guys know about i have uh
i want to give dawah i want to post more
on my youtube and all this stuff and
it's like
i feel i feel burnt out before i even
started
allah and hearing this is like just a
blessing from allah alhamdulillah
so i'm like okay
okay so let's add this in here just
i'd say it's more so for us but i feel
like people could benefit from this
because they
they're gonna have clear-cut examples
for
themselves like after hearing what we
would do
for ourselves yeah so
who wants to chime in first it doesn't
have to be 100
everything but like just some some
little things where you're like okay
this is part of the 80
this is part of the 20 yeah yeah it's
kind of like what avenue are you talking
about
i think your avenues yeah okay oh like
examples
yeah you're like mine would be
specifically the mma
romney's would be specifically what he
wants to talk about and you
you would say specifically what you i
want to talk about the better
the medical field sure i'll go with
school first
then i'll talk about islam and then
inshallah i'll talk about
money first would be study
i would say the 20 the results for 80 of
my success
um uh alhamdulillah first one would be
allah
relying on allah submitting in allah
trusting in allah not
worrying about what's going to happen
fearing a test fearing a great fearing a
prophet
for fearing allah but also remembrance
of allah so
relying on allah that's first and
foremost second thing would be
um sleep so important bro
sleep is when your memory consolidates
next thing would be
practice questions right so if you have
a midterm coming up you got an exam
coming up
create questions bro i literally i don't
i do this thing called
active recall right a lot of people take
notes right
i can't believe i'm giving office away
but when you
subhanallah bro you got to live in
abundance so there's this thing where
people type notes
when they go to school they go to
lectures they literally just take notes
of everything
bro what are you doing you're literally
rephrasing something that's already on a
powerpoint
or something that's already on a
spreadsheet why don't you rather write
questions down
so for example if a powerpoint slide
says um here are the top
i don't know four uh things necessary in
this biological process right well i
would write down
one question what are the four steps in
this biological process next one would
be
what is the first step next what is the
second step that next how does the
second one
interact with the third one i would
literally create questions
that force me to when i read these
questions like flash cards
know the answer whereas when you
conventionally study
you're just like oh i remember there's
four and the first one is this
second one might be this and then you
don't really know any of them too well
you know what i mean so it's called
active recall this is really key
and third thing i would say is
micronutrients
for you know success with memory and
with
getting good grades right so vitamins
greens all that
have a lot of spinach and liver these
are the two super foods that i
rely on for school and i've been doing
that for a while
the other 80 bro colors bro i don't even
want to mention you know whether i use
my
laptop or my phone to type notes what
time i study
if i study with my eyes closed i can go
over everything or i have it in front of
me
should i write it down or type it up
narrow is important so
next thing would be islam right
so for islam that 20
that gives me 80 fulfillment of my iman
right salah and
trying to just make time for t3m bro
because this is my medium this is my
mode this is my channel through which
i can with the power of these two
brothers unite
and convey the truth the reality
right so this would be highly key i'm
not even going to say more than that not
really necessary
but just leading a righteous life to an
example
the other eighty percent of things that
only result to twenty percent
i don't think is more important like oh
did i uh
you know did i uh pray you know my
nothing i'm not saying again they're not
important but you get what i mean
did i okay did i then uh you know dwell
about
did i read every single hadith that i
could today and not do anything else
they're still important but it's not the
the 20 right because allah gives us five
pillars of islam
five mandatory things to do right am i
giving sadhaka on a regular basis
am i these are important things right
not so high priority for me would be
other things
last thing would be money if i remember
correctly so for finances i make sure
that 20
of the things i do that result to 80 of
my success would be
one all of my bills are paid so just
have enough money that
i'm at least offload that i'm not at a
negative at the end of the month
two would be i'm saving ten percent
of every dollar i earn right this is
again not to boast but this is how i
went from zero to thousands in a matter
of few
months which is saving ten percent of
every dollar that i earn every day so if
you save 10 percent everyone watching
this
save 10 all your life you would have bro
a lot dozens of thousands by now but you
don't right because people don't really
know about saving
they just have one account um you know
uh next thing would be investing
right if your money is staying in your
bank and it's neither
investing or anything you're just
staying as cash you're losing money
because of
inflation your your money is
depreciating over time so i would say
invest in something
uh all three of us uh have having
holdings in cryptocurrency
very good thing um you know mutual funds
stocks you name it
these are the big and obviously
i try to like not spend money not eat
out you know when i can
uh that's it bro this is going to result
in
the 20 the results in 80
first and foremost for all of them being
relying on allah allah gives risk
substance right sustenance from a lot is
what gives you look around
thousand as hell right now now here is
the
80 of things that only result in 20
now these 80 of things right i'm talking
about
these major big list of things that only
results 20
damn did i uh promote my fitness page on
instagram
uh to the point that i could have to the
max that i could have to get a new
client today
did i did i do this oh damn uh my crypto
went a little low today
damn what's gonna happen because it
fluctuates right it's normal yeah
little things that you're worrying about
that are not important mental energy
attributed to
you know non-resourceful things to say
the least
they're not really important uh is my
bank balance
bigger than yesterday doesn't really
matter as long as it's bigger
every week or monthly basis that's fine
you know it doesn't really matter if on
a daily basis what's happening
uh things like that bro and to throw in
the fifth one would just be you know
health and wellness
um the twenty percent that really
matters to get the eighty percent is am
i eating clean
every day learned a lot of wisdom from
uh brother ana over here number two on a
weekly basis is my weight going
you know to where i wanted to go waste
whatever you want to say
am i training that's it you're done and
am i sleeping
the 80 of things that that make only 20
of the results i don't look at these
would be things like
oh am i weighing myself every single
hour of every single day
no it doesn't really matter am i taking
melatonin or not taking monotone
am i sleeping at nine o'clock or 9 15
should i
use a blue light filter or should i not
yeah they're important but they're not
as
important you know what i mean am i uh
eating sugar
three hours before better or four hours
before bed you know or
the lego supplement the supplement
exactly yeah
the the 80 that only results 20 is the
supplement
because a supplement supplements the
bread and butter the foundation the
building block right
the the framework um am i doing
high reps and low weight or
low reps and high weight like
yeah they matter a little but bro not
that much just lift the damn weight
high intensity high volume do more sets
that's it man clock can clock out as a
man
it's not masculine to dwell on little
things
now i'm not saying be impulsive and just
do whatever and be you know think
without your
your uncle or act without your uncle but
i'm saying
it's better to make a decision then make
no decision
don't be in a state of paralysis by
analysis um i'd rather be wrong
but you know but i'd rather never be in
doubt
you feel me yeah yeah yeah it's a show
for sure
it's like when i train i i don't really
think about it too much
i basically say like you know what if i
mess up
mess up if i do it right
they were right but i'm gonna do it
either way
but romney
firstly i want to say you're more likely
to mess up when you're thinking about
messing up
all right i find that a lot when when
i'm doing anything uh but
a lot for me i'm just gonna give one
yeah what's up
y'all think we should drop this on the
main channel just so people have a
little snippet of what patreon would
look like
yeah i think so maybe a clip yeah
but look look at this this right here
this called
with winning in mind all right person
who recommended me this
and on a side note did y'all see that
comment where someone said don't
don't take your um was it
yeah akida from ferraza hobby i was like
bro this comment doesn't make
any sense who said i was taking my my
akita
you literally didn't even say that you
literally said that y'all know who
frozobby is
he said that men don't know the reality
of violence how is that a pita
yeah yeah yeah so i was i thought that
was dumb anyways
uh with winning in mind bro what you
just said he says
in this book where he's like um if you
tell someone
like if someone's playing baseball and
you tell them like bro whatever you do
don't strike out bro in your mind
you're gonna be thinking oh let me not
strike out let me not strike out ooh
you striked out but if you tell someone
bro whatever you do
hit the ball you're like okay all i
gotta do is hit the ball
that you're more likely to hit the ball
it's like when me and my friend were
sparring
he kept throwing hits at me but he kept
missing because i have really fast
footwork
and i know how to slip and evade and
everything like that and then bro
like after we took a break we drank some
water and then we were putting the
gloves back on
i was like bro all you got to do is hit
and then he's like i bet
yeah yeah that makes sense and then he
started hitting me bro
but go ahead continue subhanallah that's
a good point
i'm glad you brought the examples
they're really helpful for me i'm just
going to bro
let me let me see something real quick
what's up i don't know why
but i literally like bro alhamdulillah
my memory
because i remember i saw this a couple
months ago if not
even over a year or two ago you posted
this on your
the real on her instagram and you wrote
something along the lines of
uh if you are you know the best version
you saw something like that and you're
trying to get to the next level
was that this book yes
yeah i remember you you you recommended
that yes
i did yeah it's a pound of love bro
hyrami no interruptions
and the floor is yours
if you guys watch the funniest moments
you all know what i'm talking about this
one yeah yeah yeah
uh ramen was like all right guys no
interruptions and then when i started
talking it's because like
bismillah yeah yeah yeah i remember that
i remember that
remember yeah yeah go ahead go ahead bro
oh my god man good times okay
so only i'm only gonna give one example
uh bismillah
so uh with me and youtube i
always uh i always over analyze things
and i'm a perfectionist with a lot of
things which is really detrimental
because i'm i'm worried about things
like oh is the camera too far is it too
close what is the what is the setting
look like is the keyboard in the way
all these little things that probably
don't really matter um
when i could just focus on things like
okay have
you know a good enough setup make sure
i'm in the shot they can see me clearly
the quality is okay um i have my points
in order
and then i have a little script some you
know points to go off of and just make
the damn video
like it's really it doesn't it doesn't
take a lot to make a decent video
right um but if you want to go for the
hundred percent
you could you know work that extra mile
and do a lot more work but
it's not really necessary with with
short videos like that it's not really
necessary i'm not writing a full like
scholarly report i'm just making a short
short clip so um inshallah i'm going to
start incorporating
you know that principle into uh into
videos and stuff now
yeah mashallah it makes sense man it's
like
the 20 that's going to give you the 80
is just making the damn videos
yeah that's right you don't understand
like how much i went through that with
youtube
but it's like i'll be like no no but i
got to make the video
perfect like the details the title the
thumbnail
the tags you know
yeah bro like i started thinking about
this stuff i'm like yo
just make the damn videos dude i said
bro sometimes i might go through like
weeks or months where i'm like too
analytical and i might put up like
one two three or four videos within that
time span
and then there's other times when i'm
like you know what forget it i'm just
going to make videos
and then i'm rob i'll bust out like 12
to 20 videos within that same time span
i thought i bought 12 to 20 nuts
how about that i know you did once upon
a time
though yeah once upon a time i don't do
that anymore
i just but yes
yes if i had to say it for myself okay
if i
speak in terms of mma yeah
20 that's giving me the 80 will be
training because you're not going to get
better if you're not
training mma
i could think about mma i could think
about fighting i could think about
spawning but i'm not going to get better
so i actually do it
uh number two for like the 20
that's giving me the 80 would be
[Music]
technique work sparring
and you know footwork hand-eye
coordination stuff
yeah good stuff like that and then like
the 80
that's um only giving me 20 would be
like
corrective exercises like you guys know
like face pools
you guys know the um band walks where
you put like a
you put like a band right between your
legs or
like wrapped around your legs you do
like the hip band walks of the headband
ladders
stuff like that um strengthening
exercises to strengthen the the arch
and the muscles in your feet because
like believe it or not like the stronger
your feet are
the quicker you can move the stronger
you can throw a punch
or uh yeah the stronger you throw a
punch stronger you throw kick knee
elbows whatever it is
it's like there's so many things but
it's like all those other things are
just
eighty percent of that twenty percent
and the last thing that i forgot to add
to the twenty percent that's giving
eighty percent is sleep
bro i had said it for his thing but it's
like
bro you do not realize how important
sleep
is till you get good sleep man sleep
quality and timing
said there's there's a something about
the early hours of the morning
after fajr you got to be productive
fellas you got to you got to get your
stuff done
this is not the time to sleep through it
or you know
you kind of just do fudgie kind of just
be zoned out if you want to meditate
reflect
go for it but get stuff done take a nap
later you know
go to sleep a little earlier reminding
myself first and foremost for any of
these things that i'm saying but
it goes without saying that sleep is
important nonetheless um
what's your next one bro no that's it i
just want to talk about and mate
but um something that i did i didn't
want to talk about sleep yeah
we're sleeping bro i spent months
getting poor quality sleep thinking like
ah
i guess it's all right i mean there are
certain fighters who
they don't get good sleep either and
they ask them like oh how do you
get a good night's sleep he's like i
never get a good night's sleep so
it doesn't matter if i sleep or not and
i'm like damn but like imagine if you
would have been getting that sleep and
then like just
recently i've been trying out a few
things that helped me out to get like
really good quality sleep to where like
i i'll do ashwagandha
i know you can't do in the asparagus but
um i'll do ashwagandha
um i do reishi mushroom
y'all heard of reishi oh
bro look it up that stuff is good
um on top of that i've been adding
melatonin
at night if i really need it i'll take a
hot shower bro like
an hour before bed get me super relaxed
um i'll try to be off electronics by
like two hours at least
before bed sometimes i can't sometimes
just one hour if i'm over here
playing call of duty with y'all or
something or if i'm just
being an idiot and i'm on my phone
hooking up something for no reason
uh but also
also one thing that i have been noticing
i tend to wake up throughout the night
and if i wake up
um it takes a bit for me to fall back
asleep now just think about it if you're
waking up
and then it takes a bit for you to fall
asleep like think about how that would
play
with the amount of sleep quality you get
on that y'all just think about that for
a second all right
and we play with it a lot so i'm over
here
just looking for like okay how can i get
this sleep on point
and like have you all ever heard of a
weighted blanket yeah
y'all heard about that yeah bro
apparently it's uh it takes away anxiety
and stress and all that
geez bro i just found out about that for
the first time like a few days ago
i'm not probably one of y'all i'm not
gonna look into that bro cause i like
i like using no blanket bro trust me
dude i like using no blanket too but
then it's like
you know what if it actually makes my
sleep on point
like i'm gonna use it bro yeah i'm gonna
use it
hold up oh you said all the all the
things you said so far are part of the
20
this is all part of just sleep
okay for the hundred percent
no i would say i said twenty percent
eighty percent
no twenty percent of the things that's
like eighty and sleep was one of those
things for 20
that's part of the 80 but in sleep it
goes even deeper where it's like okay
in order for me to get the best quality
sleep bro i'm over here looking for like
all these things bro
i'm only talking about sleep too bro but
for me
for sleep specifically the 20 that leads
to the best quality sleep
would be just timing would be the length
of the sleep
would be uh making sure it's pitch black
like no light
maybe a little bit of a salt lamp um and
not eating right before i slept or
drinking water
these are the main things that are in
the water the
80 of things that lead to the 20 for me
is did i take calcium did i take
magnesium did i take melatonin
did i uh take a hot shower or cold
shower today
you know did i drink any caffeine did i
pay attention and energy
to what if i ate four hours or five
hours before these are the things that
are not so important
did i sleep with one leg over the
blanket or both legs you know what i
mean
yeah yeah one of the things for me
i used to think that uh meditation was
like a big part
that would let me get better quality
sleep but it's like i'm realizing you
know what
if i'm relaxed with like a hot shower
if i take some melatonin and like
i've already been sleeping around the
same time every night like bro
i really don't need to meditate before
bed i prefer to do it because it like
gets me in the mood better like
sometimes i don't even have to
but anyways yeah i think
they tell your wife you tell your wife
hey baby wait up you go into the corner
you start meditating for like 10 20
minutes and you're like i am ready for
you
yo yo on a side note when i was uh with
my ex-fiance
okay uh there was one time
where uh things were about to become a
little bit haram
i didn't know what's happening was this
yeah i don't know bro
romney wants to make us look like we're
submissive
huh giving you a standing uh
ovation here yeah i'm giving a standing
ovation oh my gosh
listen now let him stand let him stand
understand so uh
i was with my ex my fiance bro and we
were in new york
in this hotel room and like we
you know she was taking a shower and um
she told me to come in the shower bro
and at the time bro i was
listen i was so focused on like oh i'm
gonna do this uh
this like nail rubbing exercise bro and
she was taking a shower like oh
i'ma join you in a second bro i was just
i was sitting there rubbing my damn
nails while she was taking a shower bro
what what does that achieve nail rubbing
uh supposedly it's called the
ground balayam and um when you're
rubbing it it's
it's um pressure point therapy
to where it it's creating certain
pressure that
connecting to uh something in your scalp
that releases blood flow
and um supposedly it works but i can
never do it long enough before my nails
start like
getting all brittle and breaking yeah my
boy sounding like a new age spiritual
nut i'm not though guys
we should wrap this up yes we can't have
this as long as an episode but
somehow it is yeah uh and listen
anyone made it this far uh this is
essentially what we do on patreon
right so yeah we're gonna put on youtube
but
like this is a very good example of what
you get the content you get on patreon
it's a little less to one topic but you
still we still aim to give value
nonetheless
a little more you know casual a little
less formal you know obviously you could
see romney in the weird striptease pose
but yeah man it is what it is uh we
thank you all for tuning in
okay and until next time
in description
how do you say uh i don't know forget it
they understand bro
my boy real quick english nah i can't we
can't put that i cursed a lot when i
said that bro
all right
salamo lego
we're gonna make this video for y'all so
y'all can see
what we got going on the patreon
and then cut right there that's straight
you're gonna have to edit out one of the
words
you just do it again bro no no that was
straight that was bro honestly that was
straight
because it's worth it you can cut it out
and then you can put in i'm saying like
when you're saying it you can either
beep it out i wouldn't beat it up
because no one's really gonna understand
but like when you're doing subtitles
you can basically like put stars so they
know like oh that was a curse for it
like this man you know
the it's going down i'm just leaving
[Music]
[Music]
um